you know a lot of people are wondering
right now how is the NBA how are they
going to start up again is there a way
some people have proposed that maybe
there could be a bubble city a place
like Vegas where all the players can get
together they can all stay in the same
hotel and play that way I don't know if
that's an insane idea or not and maybe
do it without crowds do you see anything
like that happening in the NBA soon I
don't have an answer I wish I had an
answer for you you know but kudos to all
the league commissioners and guys that
run the league for having the balls to
say you know what I care about the
players and I care about the fans
this thing's gonna spread like this we
don't want to want to you know get out
of control but as a player I don't think
I could could have a great impact
without fans you so the fans are if
you're playing the fans are that crucial
to your experience as a player yes yes
and you know for me it's not all about
the fans like I just used to pick two or
three people so when it was in LA jack
Adam Sandler Denzel and then I pick a
father and a son to just look at cuz my
dad used to always take me to the game
and be like you see that guy right there
you see his son he paid all his damn
money make sure you put on the show so
like yes fans very important like if I
go to a game and saw you there
oh I'll be like hey Conan's here he's
not here to see you though many goddamn
ball and watch me go to work I'm glad I
would have that impact on you you might
if you saw me you might say hey who's
that lady
[Laughter]